Вони погодилися не погоджуватися. Такий короткий підсумок прощальної зустрічі Анґели Меркель і Джо Байдена
в контексті "Північного потоку-2", яка відбулася за лічені дні після зустрічі канцлерки ФРН з президентом Володимиром Зеленським.
У цих світових лідерів різні погляди на суперечливий газопровід, але стратегічне партнерство
і дружба між Вашингтоном і Берліном важливіші, переконані політики.
Тож нових американських санкцій не буде і труба спокійно добудовується.
Принаймні в одному і Анґела Меркель, і Джо Байден намагалися показати єдність - це підтримка України.
Поки декларативна, але доволі чітко висловлена.
Ми говорили про Росію та Україну. У цьому контексті ми також говорили про "Північний потік-2",
і в нас різні погляди на те, що передбачає цей проєкт.
Але я хочу чітко сказати: наше розуміння було і є таким, що Україна залишається транзитною державою для природного газу
і що Україна має право, як будь-яка країна, на територіальний суверенітет.
Ось чому ми також беремо участь у мінському процесі.
Ми також будемо діяти активно, якщо Росія не поважатиме право України на транзит.
Це означає для мене, що "Північний потік-2" є додатковим проєктом, а не заміною транзиту газу через Україну.
А все інше викликало б дуже велику напругу.
Якщо будуть проблеми з транзитом газу територією Україну, Німеччина може діяти не тільки самостійно, але й спільно з ЄС, запевнила Меркель.
Вона нагадала, що саме через інструменти Євросоюзу запроваджувалися санкції проти Росії.
Через "Північний потік-2", сподівається канцлерка, не доведеться ухвалювати подібні рішення.
У свою чергу Джо Байден заявив, що Росія не повинна використовувати енергетику як зброю і пояснив,
чому Вашингтон не запроваджував нові санкції проти газопроводу.
Мій погляд на "Північний потік-2" відомий. Гарні друзі можуть не погоджуватися.
І на той час, коли я став президентом, він був завершений на 90 відсотків, і запровадження санкцій не мало сенсу,
а мало сенс працювати з канцлеркою, щоб дізнатися, як вона діятиме, якщо Росія намагалася б якимось чином шантажувати Україну.
І тому ми з канцлеркою попросили наші команди розглянути практичні заходи, яких ми могли б вжити разом,
якщо енергетична безпека, безпека України посилюється або послаблюється у зв’язку з російськими діями.
Тож ми подивимось, ми подивимось.
"Північний потік-2" став каменем спотикання у відносинах США і Німеччини в епоху президентства Дональда Трампа.
Ситуація змінилася, коли на посаді президента США його змінив Джо Байден.
Він, як і його попередник, не схвалює цей проєкт, і все ж досвідчений політик вирішив, що не варто псувати відносини з Берліном через трубу.
Наприкінці травня цього року США хоч і запровадили додаткові санкції проти деяких суден і компаній, задіяних у проєкті,
але вони не зачепили оператора проєкту Nord Stream 2 AG та гендиректора Маттіаса Варінґа.
Ще шість місяців тому, після того як Джо Байден потрапив у Білий дім, я б не стверджував, я розраховував, що це може затягнутися надовго
і газопровід, можливо, не буде добудований, але зараз можна говорити з упевненістю, що добудований він буде і буде експлуатуватися.
Гарні друзі можуть де в чому не погоджуватися - такий підхід Вашингтона і Берліна до проблеми "Північного потоку-2".
Але як це виглядатиме на практиці, невідомо.
Це гарний приклад цілей, ідей, загальних домовленостей, але насправді немає стратегії, як всього цього досягти.
США, Джо Байден і багато європейських союзників категорично проти "Північного потоку-2", який кидає виклик енергетичній безпеці Європи та клімату.
Німеччина просуває проєкт. Після серйозних суперечностей взимку і навесні, загроз і санкцій, Байден дав задню,
кажучи, що вже запізно робити щось з цим. Але Конгрес сказав, що ні.
Ці санкції - не опція, а закон. Цікаво подивитися чим, все закінчиться, але поки немає конкретного плану.
Тим часом більше конкретики з самою трубою.
Це центральний диспетчерський пункт приймальні газорозподільної станції трубопроводу Eugal -
наземного продовження "Північного потоку-2" в містечку Любмін на півночі Німеччини.
Звідси інженери контролюють надходження газу з Росії в німецьку газотранспортну систему.
Коли "Північний потік-2" вступить в експлуатацію, ми будемо отримувати газ тут, і потім залежно від того, яким шляхом має відбуватися транспортування,
газ може прокачуватися через NEL, через цю нитку, через EUGAL як основний маршрут, і JAGAL, який ми теж застосовуємо, і далі в напрямку Чехії.
Але це - теорія, а на практиці все складніше. Наземне продовження "Північного потоку-2" коштувало інвесторам майже три мільярди євро.
Це найбільший інфраструктурний проєкт Німеччини.
За два з половиною роки було укладено 46 тисяч труб - двома нитками від балтійського узбережжя до кордону з Чехією.
Одна проблема - "Північний потік-2" досі не готовий.
Ми готові! Газ може надходити в будь-який день. Надії - це не те слово,
наше завдання - бути готовими до того, що газ надходить, і коли це станеться - приймати його і транспортувати.
Проте і зараз наземне продовження "Північного потоку-2" не простоює даремно - по ньому прокачується газ, що надходить по "Північному потоку-1".
У червні цього року через Eugal було прокачано близько 2 мільярдів кубометрів газу. Це приблизно 40-процентне завантаження.
Прогнозувати дату запуску "Північного потоку-2" тут не беруться.
У нас ті ж джерела, що і у вас. І ми можемо тільки спекулювати - а я цим займатися не буду.
Лише спекулювати залишається і щодо того, на що варто розраховувати українцям після запуску "Північного потоку-2"
у разі, якщо Росія посилить свою агресію щодо України.
Принаймні Джо Байден, запевняючи у непохитній підтримці суверенітету і територіальної цілісності України, зауважив.
Ми стоїмо разом і продовжуватимемо стояти разом на захисті наших союзників по НАТО на східних рубежах від російської агресії.